foreign
[Music]
executive director here at the long now
foundation and thank you for all being
here in real life
I'm particularly excited about tonight
because really in some way a lot of what
long now does is is speculative Futures
the clock the 10 000 year clock in a way
is a is a speculative future
um in in other ways things like science
fiction is a spec speculative future
shows like black mirror that take a
piece of technology and push it forward
and and make us believe in that future
for a moment is a speculative future and
it's a way of of putting an intervention
in the world that confronts us in a in
some ways physical or mental way that
changes our perspective uh in a much
more real way than just uh you know just
just a a virtual thing one of the things
that was given to me by a friend uh is
this one's robot emotions kit for when
your robot needs to have happiness so
this little chip and you know on the
back of it it reads
this trip will make you feel happiness
when encountering any of the following
cats root beer floats Fiddlers Dutch
Colonial Furniture frisbee golf seven
layer burritos and celebrity
impersonators but let's kind of a simple
object like this that puts you into that
future uh really does a lot more than
your average thing and that's what
Johanna is really trying to figure out
is how to get you into that place where
you're imagining Futures that we need to
imagine to make a better world
welcome Jonah
I'm excited to be here thanks for coming
everybody I'm Johanna Hoffman I'm an
urbanist I am a strategist I'm a
designer and I'm also the co-founder of
a studio called design for adaptation
I'll be diving in this talk into the
work that is behind my book speculative
Futures and it focuses on how
speculative design and storytelling
tactics can be used to address
long-standing issues in Urban
Development and specifically I explore
the field of speculative Futures as the
title of the book indicates
to really articulate how we can use
these tools to co-create the resilient
cities that this Century really demands
this is a shot of Lake Oroville which is
a critical reservoir for the State of
California
for me it's a visual reminder of how
20th century systems are not up to the
task of providing for 21st century life
because it's becoming clearer that the
upheaval of the last two years is really
an indication of the intensities that
are coming right the technological
changes the ecological extinctions the
political upheavals they are only likely
to accelerate all of which highlights
the fact that we can't look to the past
as a template for what's coming creating
more resilient development really
demands that we look beyond the logic of
what we know now and imagine what else
can be
so given this pressing need for
imagination people in Urban Design and
development could be leading the push
for proactive adaptation but for the
most part we're not this is a picture of
the Harbin opera house which is designed
by mad Architects and it's been lauded
and rightfully so for being really
Innovative when it comes to Structural
Engineering it's pretty far out looking
right
like all buildings that started out as a
figment of someone's imagination they
came up with a new approach they modeled
it they prototyped they tested they
figured out how to make it real all
projects start as speculative realities
until they're built
despite these imagination focused skill
sets emphasis in the development Fields
is still often placed on perpetuating
the status quo
so a lot of Municipal planning
departments are too underfunded they're
too understaffed to really be proactive
and pushing for that kind of adaptive
change because it's a lot easier for
projects to get funding to get permitted
when they resemble what's been done
before they're less risky giving the
mounting uncertainties at the times that
we live in that trend is becoming
increasingly dangerous for example it's
still a common practice to build in
high-risk fire zones with minimal
Protections in place this is a shot of
coffee Park up in Santa Rosa after a
burned down and a fire in 2017.
systems for building new housing are
still based on supporting population
sizes and density levels that made sense
decades ago not today and that's made
our construction rates slow to the point
that we're in the affordable housing
crisis that we're in right now
building in floodplains still common
practice this is a shot of flooding in
Western Germany from 2021
this is Manhattan in 2021 during
Hurricane Ida
this is Kentucky this past summer
the mounting severity of these crisis
done from the fact that we are in a
larger crisis of limited imagination we
have limited imagination about what our
cities are about the conditions that
they're facing and about what we need
them to be in coming decades and that
limited imagination is in part the
result of a long-standing trend in Urban
Development that sees the future largely
as a place to be predicted and
controlled even with the best research
and foresight cities are going to
continue to morph in ways that we can't
predict again the past is not a
sufficient template for where we're
headed
we also have limited imagination about
whose Visions are value in City making
and that Trend perpetuates Urban
development's long-standing trends of
exclusion for Generations
the work of City making has really
limited public participation in order to
minimize opposition and accelerate Bill
work and a lot of communities have been
dismissed disenfranchised and displaced
as a result
setting the stage for a lot of the
social and economic inequities that are
plaguing cities today so a lot of you
might be familiar with the phenomenon of
urban renewal that shapes so much of
20th century development in the US and
Beyond and it was a mode of cleaning up
but at the time were often denser cities
making them more spacious a lot of times
Greener what Urban has thought at the
time were going to be better places for
people to live a lot of these
redevelopments focused in places but
communities of color the residents of
which were rarely consulted and often
displaced as a result so this is a shot
of a demolition Zone in the Hill
district of Pittsburgh in 1957 while I
was going through one of these urban
renewal processes here in San Francisco
The Fillmore neighborhood was a
particular Target of urban renewal the
movement enacted really devastating
effects on the city's black community
that are still being felt over half a
century later around 20 000 people were
displaced by these urban renewal
projects and many were resettled in
substandard housing an environmentally
polluted areas so like so many during
the urban renewal craze residents there
uprooted and removed and that Urban
renewal's height for every four units of
low-income housing that were destroyed
for every new one that was built so
we're just like having this decimation
of affordable housing going on over a
prolonged period of time and more than
two-thirds of the displaced were Black
Or Hispanic people
so in the years since that kind of
development has been increasingly
decried which is great but its effects
unfortunately are still very much with
us so when we're thinking about
presenting Futures as predictable which
is oftentimes what happens when they are
used in order to displace people right
we convince people that what's being
proposed is the right thing to do even
if it causes repercussions that are
harmful we have to use them as Prime
forums for persuasion by grounding them
in today's logic when we place borders
around our Collective imagination it
makes long-standing issues appear
increasingly intractable and dystopian
future is much more inevitable by the
day
given how dark current conditions can
feel at times it's easy to understand
why imagining Alternatives can feel so
difficult this is a shot of the city we
are in right now San Francisco fall of
2020 it was frightening so cold on the
ground because the heat of the sun
couldn't reach us it was literally
orange and red out day I still feel
traumatized and it was hard to remember
that Armageddon wasn't going to continue
forever but the truth is that it's not
the future's not a given and if we don't
want dystopia to be our inevitable
trajectories we have to think
differently and more creatively about
what can be the things that we picture
in our minds are what we're more primed
to accept to embrace to enact and if we
want more resilient cities we need to
shake off the limits that we place on
our own imaginations
speculative Futures are design
approaches that essentially create high
resolution visions of potential
realities so they're all about
collapsing that distance that's between
tomorrow and right now so that they can
help us reflect on the ramifications of
potential change to inform the decisions
that we make today so the idea is the
more high resolution your understanding
of a potential future is you can refine
whether or not it's where you actually
want to go once you decide on a future
that you might prefer for yourself you
can then think through backtrack to the
present moment so you can identify steps
that might actually be able to take you
there so a well-known version of one
type science fiction prototyping is Star
Trek a lot of tools that we now use on
The Daily I see it in some people's
hands like tablet computers or devices
that translate language as they're being
spoken were shown in early versions on
this show people were very inspired by a
lot of these demonstrations of these at
the time fictional tools and in the
decades afterwards have made them into
real life it also showed a more racially
Progressive and gender equal future the
one was going on at the time and that's
another powerful aspect of speculative
Futures approaches that they can
critique what's happening that's often
taken as a given in the present moment
and help us think through what
alternatives might actually be
so World building is another kind of
speculative Futures approach this is an
image from the movie Minority Report
which is set around the time frame of
2050-ish and to build the world the
filmmakers had to research what 2050-ish
could be like it wasn't just about
looking into the technologies that could
happen it was also about diving into
what political systems might be like
what are the ecological contexts what
are the cultural norms and the flood was
so successful at grounding but at the
time were really Fringe areas of
research responsive targeted advertising
or touch screen tag like that wasn't
around when it came out in the early
2000s that it led to hundreds of patents
in the years since because we could
really see how these things might impact
daily life
these days some speculative features are
designed to be experiential in digital
form this example is from bidibon for
slate which is a VR exploration of a
climate change Toronto by the First
Nation artist Lisa Jackson so as you put
on these VR goggles you explore what
Toronto could be it's hotter it's wetter
and you also hear the languages of
different First Nation people the wendot
the Ojibwe the Mohawk as they're moving
through this world so you're connecting
to different aspects of its past it's
present as you are also exploring its
future
another approach is design fiction these
are typically ways of creating
prototypes of tools that occur in a
given scenario what Sanders showed us at
the beginning is very much a design
fiction another example that I love is
called ayapa repository and it's a 2016
advert by two artists ayoda molo
akusende and salomeya Sega and they made
basically a museum and a resource
library of objects that affirm the
futures of black people so they got
together with some different community
members they brainstormed what some of
these objects might be that can support
black life in coming years and then they
made them into objects so very much from
like the afrofuturism tradition of doing
this work another speculative Futures
tactic is speculative design which is
basically a form for using design to
challenge assumptions about current
conditions and Convention this
particular project is hyphen lab's
neurospeculative afrofeminism Salon
which re-envisions a black hair salon as
a lab for neuro cosmetology and
cognitive enhancement so again
challenging the idea of what a black
hair salon can be and doing it in high
resolution fashion
some speculative Futures use more simple
tactics
this is a project by the artist candy
Chang she did a series after Hurricane
Katrina in New Orleans in the mid 2000s
and she covered buildings that had been
made Vincent and abandoned After the
Storm occurred and she covered them with
these stickers asking people to add
their ideas of what they wish those
buildings were instead and its
Simplicity gets to the heart of really
what speculative Futures are all about
their means of asking what if and why
not what else can exist here in place of
what is right now
so the process of proactively engaging
with the future and these personal high
resolution tactile ways is something
that researchers find increases are
resilience as individuals and as
societies the more we imagine what the
future can be the stronger our abilities
to engage with longer time frames become
the more we do that the more we look
into longer time frames the more
frequently we end up challenging
assumptions and current conventions the
more we challenge those assumptions the
more that our senses of autonomy and
resilience start to expand so doing this
work can make us more resilient on
individual levels
the more we imagine the future together
the more socially resilient we often
become social resilience is essentially
a different community's ability to adapt
cope deal with different kinds of Social
and environmental hazards and
researchers are finding that just as
important as ecological and
infrastructural resiliences social
resilience is just as critical this
picture
is an image of Chicago's 1995 Heatwave
which killed hundreds of people across
the city and researchers have found in
the decades since that communities that
whether the event more safely where less
people died were those where people knew
each other they were socially resilient
because they were socially connected so
while infrastructural resilience for
example can take large amounts of time
and money to achieve social resilience
are connections to each other the
institutions that hopefully support us
is a more immediate opportunity that
still has very real impact
so researchers have found that stronger
degrees of collaboration and reciprocity
are an effective means of enhancing that
aspect of social resilience so
collaboration is a way of deepening
trust and connection also lays the
groundwork for self-determination all of
which can be very critical to enhancing
resilience
so speculative Futures tactics help us
do this work help us build these
Connections in a few different ways one
is by cultivating possibility through
play
so one example of what this can look
like is a project called the Republic of
Columbus being and it was an effort that
was led by an artist named Jorge Manos
Rubio while he was working in Columbus
spring which is a neighborhood in West
Amsterdam
so residents in the area come from a lot
of different cultures which has resulted
in some conflict over the years and
after trying some more traditional
measures to address these issues local
government asked different artists and
designers to try some more experimental
tactics so Manos Rubio worked with
residents in the area to come up with
the idea of turning the local square
into a micronation so even though he was
the one who came up with this initial
concept of creating a micronation he
used speculative Futures tools to invite
The Wider Community to inhabit it and
explore what it meant to create this
alternative reality in the moment
so they use speculative Futures tactics
to invite different members of the
community into this process they made
their own money passport stamps design
fictions they created a National Space
Agency they visited the actual European
space agency but they also came back to
Columbus being to the micronation of
Columbus Spain and used Tyvek kites to
test out what their own future rocket
launches could be
they created their own Olympic sports
teams so as the months progressed
the square became a sanctioned
micronation acknowledged in Amsterdam
but also by other micronations worldwide
it was a place where residents could
start to imagine that they were citizens
of their own shared nation state and
live out the ramifications of doing so
in real time
so this was a kind of play this was an
experimentation and it was also a way of
stepping again temporarily out of the
conflict Zone that was this present
State between people who had a lot of
differences with each other and it
wasn't about ignoring the fact that
those differences existed it was about
saying what else can also exist here and
then creating a space to work through
and have collaborative discussion about
what else that could be in creating
trust to different degrees in the
process this is not to say that this
solved all of Columbus beans issues
because it did not but it was again a
way of cultivating new degrees of trust
I shared identity and a certain sense of
belonging
so speculative Futures also invite us to
not just think about the future but to
use our senses in order to feel it
and that can be a way of making the
future I feel like a really personal
place so this is a shot from a 2017
project called the Future Energy lab
created by the studio superflex for the
government of the United Arab Emirates
superflex created a series of
interactive experiential Futures
installations with the goal of
influencing the country's energy
policies so they identified five
different energy scenarios that could
occur in the country up to the year 2050
and they made an energy simulator
role-playing game different interactive
objects so that different decision
makers the Prime Minister was involved
the head of cabinet they could explore
what these different Energy Futures
would be again by feeling into and
exploring in tactile ways with the
ramifications could go down as so in one
scenario people got to smell the air
that might occur if current fossil fuel
emissions rates continued so it was a
pretty noxious mix of carbon monoxide
nitrous oxide it smelled like rotten
eggs and it was an experience that
allowed people to not just think about
air quality in the future but to really
feel it to experience it I'm borrowing a
phrase from Stuart candy who's a long
now fellow and a former colleague of
mine that speculative Futures this work
helps us to not just see into the future
but feel into the future and when we do
so we can start to really relate to the
Future as a fundamentally personal place
which it really is we will be living
some of us at least 30 years from now
our children our grandchildren will be
living there the speculative features
can also be a powerful way of balancing
between the parts of our brain that work
with long-term vision and other parts
that are more focused on the here and
now because speculative Futures tools
really focus on different narrative
aspects that can be a way of again
linking the specific and the personal to
initiate the balance between these two
time frames so one example of what that
can look like is a 2010 project called
anaropa this used speculative design for
an exploration of what Europe might look
like in 2050. so the project depicted
this future based on renewable energy
production where Europe's old boundaries
are dissolved replaced by new fictional
states that are shaped by the type of
renewable energy that each one is
capable of generating
so these are new speculative States with
names like hydropia that's where all the
hydropower comes from Solaria that's
where all the solar power is generated
and they're connected by a centralized
energy grid so this grid serves to
redistribute renewable energy across the
continent according to season this is
obviously fanciful but it's also based
on detailed research they looked at
greenhouse gas emissions they looked at
infrastructural conditions and they
found that the European Union at the
time was the third largest producer of
greenhouse gas and they also pursued
sustainable energy projects and really
haphazard ways like lots of solar farms
in dark parts of Germany wind farms in
parts of Italy where there's not a lot
of wind
so anaeroba becomes a whole-scale
redesign of the entire continent
reorienting renewable energy projects
according to geographic location
Reaching Across the Mediterranean to
also include parts of North Africa and
it's not a viable plan it was never
intended to be reorganizing an entire
continent by energy infrastructure and
also by geopolitical borders like it's
out there and that was the intention
instead anaropa becomes a framework to
assess the technical and the economic
feasibility of achieving really large
scale reductions designers here were
intentionally trying to be provocative
in order to spark wider conversations
and they did that successfully this was
covered by Outlets like the guardian it
was debated on parliamentary Halls
so the findings from its backtracking
process again identifying a potential
future that we could move towards and
looking to see what steps we would take
now in order to move in that trajectory
was really the point and it ended up
those identified steps influencing
certain aspects of policy
recommendations
so instead of providing a concrete
destination anaropa was a way of asking
if we're going to achieve massive
reductions in 40 years what should we do
now
speculative Futures tactics I'm thinking
World building here in particular are
also powerful in part because they help
us find shared language
so this image is from a project that I
worked on in 2020 called future World
Vision and it was a project I worked on
with the World building Studio
experimental design and the American
Society of civil engineers and we built
an interactive educational virtual
reality video game that explored what
urban life could be in 2070. so we made
it in collaboration with a range of
stakeholders experts on diverse fields
we were talking with people like
material scientists anthropologists
you know technologists Community
organizers and we made it as a way so
that we could start to find Common
Ground across these different areas of
expertise and we did that in part by
Framing the city as a question as a kind
of provocation because this was made
primarily for engineers the questions
that we asked were things like what does
transit systems become in 50 years again
trying to provoke a certain open space
we don't know the answers we're very
curious as to what the questions could
be and we use story spaces
as ways to help people relate to what
this could look like on a personal level
so a lot of our research which you can
see over on the right side of this image
translated into fictional science
fiction stories about people's daily
lives and that was really just a
dialogue so when we went back for these
workshops we could say hey this is what
we think might would happen like what do
you think and again really taking
people's feedback from very different
backgrounds expertise orientation
seriously and refining our designs our
proposals our story lines accordingly
taking that into visual 3D form as well
and again always across scales
multifunctional Transit quarters for
example have to function as a city scale
but they also impact life at the ground
scale how do those scales impact each
other
so as our city got more detailed we
could ask our collaborators deeper
questions so this process of iteration
and communication over time was a way of
creating a context where people from
disparate backgrounds could start to
speak an increasingly shared language
this video game Space became a forum for
collaboration for dialogue for different
degrees of co-creation so speculative
Futures can also be ways of pushing
Beyond participation and inclusion two
more robust modes of co-creation one
example of what this can look like in
practice comes from a project in LA
this one is called Sankofa City it ran
from 2014 to 2019. and the South La
neighborhood of lemur Park which is a
site of a lot of heated discussions
about cultural displacement and
gentrification
so this was initiated by Limerick Park
residents and students from USC's
Department of cinematic arts and local
residents wanted to see how they could
use different kinds of creative
collaboration and place making to
strengthen the neighborhood sense of
identity and create stronger cultural
connections that new arrivals could also
understand and embrace and the goal was
really to spark public conversation
about again the future trajectory of the
neighborhood and so they decided in
these kind of what if
provocation-oriented way let's kind of
focus on something that a lot of people
seem to be both curious about and also a
little freaked out by which is emerging
Technologies of augmented reality and
autonomous Transit what happens when
this neighborhood has augmented reality
and autonomous Transit on wide scale
widespread levels so instead of using
local feedback you know students from
USC coming in to propose an idea and
saying hey what do you guys think of
this they really use speculative Futures
tools to co-create this exploratory
process from from the beginning
and so I had a lot of workshops did a
lot of design fiction stood a lot of
speculative Design This was an iterative
process where people came together over
15 times over the course of many many
months and as the workshops progressed
participants started playing with the
idea that their neighborhood wasn't just
a future version of lemur Park but it
was actually a different place entirely
it was called sankopa City and they
decided Sankofa City had some primary
values community-based policing it had
education through gardening
I had complementary autonomous cars that
were built and designed by local shops
so with each session again this
refinement process started to go deeper
more detailed
and the Visions generated in Sankofa
City gave residents a more cohesive idea
about how they wanted lemur Park to
transform and more agency and advocating
for their preferences and today local
residents are building on some of those
Visions by basically fundraising to
enact some of them in real life so one
local leader a man named Ben Caldwell
he's gotten some federal funding to
start to prototype with some of these
free autonomous shuttles could look like
and he's using them as opportunities to
do skill building with local youth in
the area which is a big example of the
power of creating narratives and visions
that are rooted in place when the story
is being told really belong to us when
they are rooted in our communities and
our neighborhoods we're inherently more
connected to what those stories show and
it's often the case that we can push
generated ideas more effectively to the
next level of impact and it's why
storytelling is a key part of
cultivating sustained investment in the
ideas of what our cities can be it's
wise by get a Futures can help us also
enact City making that go beyond mere
inclusion like rather than acting as the
experts in the room professionals like
me can start to use speculative Futures
to welcome residents as co-designers
rather than feeling pushed aside
residents can start to use these tools
to advocate for visions that really work
for them and push designers like me to
listen to adapt to co-create because the
ways that we imagine the future
fundamentally impact the products the
infrastructure and the cities that we
end up creating the phenomenon of 20th
century urban renewal that I touched on
in the beginning of this talk was
inspired in large part by a guy named
Ebenezer Howards
designs for what he called The Garden
City this Garden City that influenced so
much of 20th century developed in some
pretty negative ways started out as
somebody else's imagination what we
imagine it's powerful
these days our Collective imagination
skews pretty dystopian when it comes to
thinking about the future and we see
that in the books we read in the movies
that are out there and it's not to say
that dystopian fantasy is bad it can be
a really powerful way of really
questioning current issues and sounding
the alarm and yet when so much of it is
so dystopian it can be really hard on a
wider level to think that alternatives
are possible Right dystopia tells us
like do less despair more
when we don't push back against
dystopian narratives they can
increasingly become real life one of my
favorite movies is very dark anybody
else a Blade Runner fan
right it's a great movie and it's also a
really scary vision of what urban life
can become
and it's become increasingly influential
in urban space since it came out now
about almost 40 years ago Sid me the
same visual designer who created the
Blade Runner aesthetic consulted on a
lot of building projects in the Gulf
region before he died in 2019. Blade
Runner's influence also extends much
farther around the world the picture on
the left here is from the original movie
in 1982 the image on the right is
Beijing in 2013. the question becomes
what kind of Futures do we want to
imagine for ourselves because those are
the Futures that we are most likely to
create so speculative Futures are ways
to push Beyond dystopia and envision and
enact the Futures we want
made real the question then becomes okay
how do we do this work so there's no one
way to do it but a lot of projects that
are pretty powerful often have
engagement as a really core part of them
and the more iterative is the more it
allows for a certain again shared
language shared values trust to be built
and so this is not to say that this work
is easy or quickly done but definitely
has a lot of potency and power when it's
invested in in ways that are sincere
there are for sure opportunities to
integrate these tools into different
scales of our society and I'm not here
to tell you exactly what should be done
but I have some ideas
so when it comes to governmental levels
it could be a powerful thing to have
different Futures offices instituted
with a municipal Regional for State
systems that provide places for
imaginative co-creation to happen on an
ongoing basis because again if you have
this work that is tied directly to a
project that is already decided on and
it already has people working on it it's
going to have a way of basically
including wider populations within a
system that already has inertia and it's
not necessarily that way of provoking
collaborative conversation because
essentially that idea for what should be
done is already like well formed so how
can we have this visioning process be
available be supported be provoked on
again an ongoing basis translating those
Visions can be then a really powerful
way to inform other planning initiatives
policy recommendations and
infrastructural interventions when we're
talking about ngos research institutions
other aspects of you know Civic Society
it can be a powerful role to be a
mediator sometimes if you're talking
about collaborations between community
members who have been disenfranchised
different aspects of government there
can be very tense and mistrusting
relationships right so having different
people come in who don't necessarily
have those same roles over different
periods of time to act as meteors can be
a really powerful role also if you're a
research institution translating
research and not just papers but in
different experiential ways can be a
really powerful mechanism for helping
more of us understand some of these
changes that are accelerating and
understanding you know more and more
basically what's coming down the pike
private sector a lot of funding for
futures literacy stuff can be done
because a lot of it can be really well
framed to particular groups how is it
different to talk about these issues for
people who are under the age of 10
versus people who are over the age of
70. people who are from different
socioeconomic backgrounds
and for individuals is there an opening
to make this work personal what does it
mean to think about what your life is
going to be in 10 years in 50 years are
there similarities between where you
think you might want ahead and your
family members are there people who are
Beyond maybe your family members and
your wider Community if there are
commonalities where do modes for
collaboration start to arise are there
different organizations who are maybe
working on some of these issues where
you live that you can either donate to
maybe get involved with
because using speculative features alone
is not going to solve the many problems
that our cities face they're not a
silver bullet they're not a Panacea
their power really lies on how their
tools are harnessed and for what ends
but if we all people who live in cities
can start to accept and engage with the
fact that the futures
we have the Futures that are evolving
they're constantly in flux we can start
to get closer to creating the more
resilience cities and spaces that this
Century really demands of us
so these are tools that help us to not
just recognize those inherently shifting
contexts but to actively imagine and
co-create what they can be the more we
speculate about coming decades the
stronger we become the stronger we
become the more cooperative
the more resilient our Urban spaces
start to grow
and then speculative Futures again they
can be these ways of imagining and
implementing the future in this present
moment today which is definitely I argue
what we need a little more of thank you
um thank you we're going to reset a
little bit here
so thank you so much you're so welcome I
wanted to get back to the the part where
this dystopian versus utopian part and I
always think it's interesting as you
look back through science fiction we
seem to have waves of
utopianism and dystopianism and we seem
to be you know as as Blade Runner came
out kind of in a wave of dystopianism
um I mean I think it's it's good to have
this kind of warning Factor but it also
leaves you as you said building
potentially the wrong Futures so I
wanted to talk more about that yeah
yeah I think one of the issues with this
like dystopian utopian divide is that it
is binary and in my opinion like it's
not about aiming for one or the other
it's about saying that there is a
possibility of both incremental change
and also just that Utopia even if it's
something that we all agreed upon in
this moment would probably not stay that
way in 10 years and 20 like it changes
right and
yeah if we can aim towards something
that people like Kevin Kelly call
protopia the fact that it's not about
aiming for you know an ideal situation
but it's about acknowledging that even
in an ideal situation like complicated
things are still going to be going on
and can we just like get into the
nitty-gritty of what that is as well can
incremental positive change also be
available to us I think Kim Stanley
Robinson likes calling it uptopia it's
like Improvement as process
so yeah I feel like Utopia versus
dystopia is emphasizing one or the other
as a destination
and it's not to say that like you know
aiming towards positive Visions as like
something that is a little bit more
robust and concrete is bad but I think
acknowledging that those Visions change
and I think that's why again this
iterative process with different
speculative Futures tool set as an
ongoing practice is a really powerful
Framing and it's oftentimes not what
people want to hear because it's nice to
think that like if we just come up with
that one idea that's all we need to
focus on but it's usually not going to
be that simple yeah yeah I think it's
Paul sappho uh who's been a long time
futurist who also said that you know no
futurist ever got in trouble for
predicting a negative future but many
many get in trouble for predicting a
positive future that might not turn out
right
um and so I think this there's there's a
safety in in going negative
um which I think is is attractive
especially as you know various world
events kind of uh back it up um I'm
curious as you deal with city planners
and civil engineers man some ways civil
engineers I mean some of the greatest
story of long-term thinking we have are
these big civil engineering projects
that happen for water or you know in
some cases transportation
and City Planning they've been working
in decades and centuries for a long time
they're probably very frustrated that
the public isn't along with them and I
assume that these kind of things are
great
even though maybe they're
a difficult exercise for them to do do
are they are they welcoming to these
exercises
well I'd say that these exercises are
actually just part already of
City Planning architecture like they're
not new at all I would say though that
if you think of like the umbrella of
speculative Futures and the many
different approaches that are in them
and then you turn it 90 degrees it's a
Venn diagram with a lot of other
disciplines that also use these tools
and in the city planning architecture
realm oftentimes these rules or these
tools can be used for again prediction
and persuasion and so it's not that the
tools themselves are going to save us I
think it's like how we use them can
definitely improve things so when
they're focused a lot more on this
provocative aspect
using humor right challenging again
conventions being a little bit more
playful that can be the way to harness
them in order to facilitate more
co-creative collaborative envisioning
and then action because yeah I would say
that in architecture and planning for
sure in my own professional experience
oftentimes it's about coming up with
really sexy images because when you do
that everyone's like well that looks
yeah let's do that one and it's not as
if that's a bad thing like it can be so
amazing to be inspired by something that
looks great but if you only put blue
skies in your renderings in order to
sell people an idea when you actually
think through the impacts might not
necessarily be that blue like there's
not always going to be blue skies It's
Gonna Rain sometimes can we just I bet
that image of Beijing they sold that
building with the blue sky behind it for
sure
yeah so let's like get into the
nitty-gritty when we work on these
things and create openings and forums
for us to do that with others so this
co-creative process that I think these
tools can invite because again we're not
all trained as planners and Architects
but we all have imaginations so how can
that become the basis for how
collaboration can start to deepen and I
thought a powerful point that you
brought up is this idea that so much of
how we design the future is people think
it's the safest move is to use the
lessons from the past even though
clearly our future has is changing much
faster than it has in the past
um so I'm wondering
as city planners are are doing this it's
it feels like the safe thing but now
it's is it becoming apparent that it's
not more readily or is or you know is it
always going to be easier to sell a past
idea first I don't want to speak for all
city planners because like you know
there's a lot of us and I do think that
yeah there's a lot more discussion of
like we're in serious trouble we need to
do stuff and so for me I think like what
this book was about was how are tools
that are already a part of the planning
and design process how can they be more
widely used so that more of us can
cultivate our own agency so that we can
work with people like me who have often
times in the past been that people are
like I know best because like I went to
school so like you should listen to me
when it's really about more of us doing
this work of thinking through what works
for us because yeah nobody no one person
no narrow group no group of experts is
going to have the answer I can maybe
know better like what permitting process
you need to go through or like what has
worked for other cities when it comes to
like the kind of Street trees like
there's room for expertise for sure but
I think it needs to be implemented
within a context where more of us are
able to say like actually
hold up this is what I've thought
through and let's talk about like us
coming from all a place of power and
agency and advocating for our
preferences yeah I think that that
immersive part is key right where you
it's it's the way that you get community
members into the design process and as
opposed to just having something handed
down from City Hall yeah yeah
yeah and I think at the end of the day
it's really about collaborative decision
making how can we do the often difficult
and frustrating work of making decisions
together you know it's not always easy
to talk with other people who live in
our cities right we have different like
busy schedules for sure we have
different ways of doing things we have
different ideas different socioeconomic
backgrounds a lot of just like
differences and so I think these can be
tools to work with our differences and
use the imaginative play space that can
be a really like less charge sometimes
or at least like more inviting place to
create some openings for some of those
collaborative discussions to start to at
least initiate if not to deepen
and I know you know a lot of the
founders of long now are part of global
business Network whose main thing that
they did was do scenario planning for uh
various agencies and one of their
biggest issues that was always kind of
dicey is they would often create you
know extreme scenarios and like black
mirror in a way is like an extreme
scenario that show if you if you've seen
it basically takes one idea of
technology and pushes it so far that
it's terrifying
um and so these kind of scenarios when
they get out as a Civic project freak
people out and sometimes in a good way
but I'm wondering like what's your take
on doing extreme positive or negative
scenarios or is it better to kind of
keep it in a more median Zone I like the
ambiguous situation I really love Ursula
Le guin's the dispossessed mostly for
her subtitle which is an ambiguous
Utopia because like again no Utopia no
dystopia is going to be entirely a place
where like it's all like people humans
have a way of finding a way like Blade
Runner 2049 I really did love this scene
towards the end if people have seen this
movie where like everyone's coming
together and they're like obviously
gonna foment like a you know
community-based Revolution and I was
like that's great that's probably like a
great feeling that they're all having
right there not that I want to live in a
wasteland where everything is you know
orange and gray but I like challenging
situations can sometimes really support
amazing degrees of community coming
together and that can be a beautiful
aspect you know even amidst horrible
Devastation so again I'm not
recommending or advocating or trying to
say that going towards Dark Places is a
good thing but I think presenting them
again is like one extreme are the other
I'm really interested in extreme
scenarios that also again like Julian
Bleaker is great about this and other
people at the new future laboratory
design fiction books they're like what's
an extreme situation where you're still
focusing on like you know the garbage
disposal dude like what's that like so
it's not just about like the hero's
journey who's like the one who's doing
all the crazy stuff it's like what does
it mean when you have to go to the
bathroom like are you just digging a
hole in the ground or is there actually
somebody who like has thought about that
I mean just like let's go to the basics
of the mundane experience of being a
person rather than you know thinking
about some of these contentious like War
Games often like a lot of those really
intense scenarios are really about
strategic war game assessment and trying
to figure out the roles of different
government actors or really high-powered
wealthy individuals and you know
obviously those people are probably
going to be thinking about this stuff in
a really proactive way and they have a
reason to do so all the rest of us do as
well and I'm not you know a president of
some country or like a billionaire I'm a
person who's going to be needing to
figure out like how do I get a couple
noodles when I'm really hungry
nice do we have audience questions
glad you mentioned Kim Stanley Robinson
and your comment there because my
question is about him uh one of our
favorites here and his latest book is
explicitly uh you know imagining what
the future would would might be and how
how it happened so assuming you've had
the chance to read Ministry for the
future
um you know either either what insights
were surprising or fun for you or that
you would relate to us as examples or or
how how does that fiction work is uh as
as an example of your species
perspective Futures and
Etc no great question for those of you
who haven't read Ministry of the future
it is set in a future time frame where
there literally is a Ministry of the
future who's responsible for yeah
advocating for future populations
I think what I really appreciate most
about that book and there's a lot he
does amazing research Kim talks with so
many different scientists governance
experts just like people who are really
detailed in their field and then again
he uses his science fiction to prototype
in high resolution ways what these
things can be when they come together
when you get people who are researching
how do you literally keep glaciers from
melting given our warming world with
people who are also really focused on
different aspects of just like mundane
City Community Building governance what
I really appreciate about that book is
that he gets into the really annoying
nitty-gritty again like it's not fun in
that story to like be part of the
ministry of the future it's bureaucratic
grind and so I think he shows us in an
understanding of the difficulties that
really exist in making people you know
care about people who don't exist yet or
talk about the fact that all of our
climate impacts are being felt so in
equally what's happening in Pakistan
right now after these devastating floods
is horrific and it's already people who
are in a really difficult economic
situation so he and I think in that
story isn't shying away from those
issues and he's still again in this kind
of uptopia
uh perspective again moving towards a
positive trajectory in incremental
fashion still showing us like we have a
lot of difficulties and how do you work
with them
another question in the back hi uh thank
you for your amazing presentation
um you mentioned the resiliency of
community in your presentation and I was
wondering if you can give more examples
of that more currently
um like what does it look like in
different communities
um yeah like just kind of more because
I'm just hearing a lot of like a
physical space but I'm just wondering if
there's more development with physical
space and the community aspect
um that you're seeing like using
speculative features to do that yeah
so one of them I talk about it in the
book
um but I think it's really remarkable is
akbag bloshi so it's a site in Ghana and
it's an E-Waste site mostly like it's
really been used to dump a lot of our
electronic waste for a long time
and
people there are for sure like you know
creating some environmental damage in
the process of recycling a lot of this
stuff and they're also really amazing
like prototypers and they have a really
robust circular economy so these two
different Architects got together they
had some ties to this community in
different ways and they kind of just
started hanging out with people in the
area because they wanted to like help
they wanted to improve but they also
didn't want to take this tack that a lot
of designers and planners do which is
coming in from the outside being like we
have a great idea you should do this so
they just hung out and got to know
people over time they had to get grants
to do it it definitely like wasn't easy
and they learned over the course of just
spending time there that it was also
a way of kind of like they could get
money in order to fund the work by
basically reframing this environmental
catastrophe which is happening there
which is you know significant
by reframing it as an opportunity to
augment the resilience of people in the
area through basically supporting their
economics Prosperity so they started to
co-create with people using these
speculative Futures tools a lot of
aspects of prototyping
um different ways of basically like
coming up with economic systems to help
them sell their goods because as really
great prototypers
they were really good at making things
that other people wanted so how could
they create a digital tool that you know
helped them Reach a wider customer base
so they can make more money so and
through that digital tool also make
available more information about
Environmental Protections that they
could take but doing it in a way that
was tied to the thing that people were
much more motivated by which was
becoming economically stable and in
doing so forming stronger ties with each
other greater senses of autonomy and
agency so the resilience aspect you know
what the buzzword is it the most like
useful word for what we're talking about
not always but I think what becomes
pretty powerful about it to me it's the
reason why I chose it for this book is
that it operates on different scales
again like that particular project in
aglab grocery was about like family
individual resilience and then it also
became about stronger Community agency
and resilience at this other scale
so one example
nice thank you so much thank you
[Applause]
[Music]